one of the most used implicit intents in
Android is the share intent it's awesome
it's a great way to waste time for both
you and your friends you can leverage
your favorite apps to share photos text
videos and general links and the best
part is you don't have to even know what
the users favorite apps are just tell
Android what data you want to share and
it shows your users or a list of apps
that will share it apps that may not
have existed when your app was written
to make it even easier to share Android
4.0 added the share action provider and
we have it for previous releases of
Android as part of the support library
it operates using the action send intent
if we use ratos of glorious envelope
metaphor it would be addressed to anyone
who can perform action send the data
descent would be included with it as
extras either as text or URI to the
binary data and the mime type would
indicate what the URI points to here's
what the share action provider will
bring to our app in glorious wireframe
there will be an additional icon in the
action bar which will drop down a menu
when clicked to reveal potential share
actions another icon will be added to
the right of this one that contains the
last application shared to add a share
action provider to the fragment within
detail activity it will share whether in
the following format yes it's just the
string we passed into the view plus
hashtag sunshine app